wir schauen uns heute mal die drei
schönsten Städte in Deutschland an ich
frage mich immer wer sowas entscheidet
also mein persönliches Ranking wäre
glaube ich Platz 1 Hamburg nee quatsch
Platz eins meine Heimatstadt die kennt
aber keiner ich blende euch jemand Foto
ein wunderschönen Platz zwei Hamburg
Platz 3 ich sag einfach mal vorsichtig
Nürnberg die schönsten Städte in
Deutschland
Rothenburg ob der Tauber die Altstadt
habe ich noch nie gehört aber okay die
mittelalterliche Architektur ist hier
sehr schön das Schönlein müsst ihr das
aber so sieht's auch ich schwöre so
sieht's bei mir hier in meinem
Heimatstadt Dorf aus und als Großstadt
die Hauptstadt Bayerns München den
Marienplatz in der Altstadt müsst ihr
sehen ja okay München ist auch schön für
eine Großstadt auf jeden Fall aber safe
nicht so schön wir Hamburg